Okay.
Thanks so much.
That was quite the introduction.
Thanks everyone for coming today and
thank you to Google for hosting us and Sam
for being our host today.
We really appreciate it. Um,
as many of you are probably aware,
um,
since 1990 over a billion people
have moved out of poverty globally,
which is really exciting and I think
gives us all the idea that it's possible.
Um, and that we can make significant
progress on our goals towards any global
poverty.
At the same time,
nearly a million people still live in
poverty and many more than that live
without access to financial services
live without access to health and live in
chronic and acute hunger.
Um,
and those people are disproportionately
women and people living in rural areas.
And so Grameen Foundation,
we're really committed to continuing
to find solutions that work for those
people. Um, many of the advances
that have driven global growth, um,
that have driven the in the reduction
of poverty have been global growth.
But there are also many advances
that have been due to investments and
development initiatives.
So, for example, in India,
some of you may know the unheard
system, which is the, um,
the new national identity and
biometric system in India.
Maybe some of you may have worked on it.
Um,
but India has made a
significant investment in
making sure that every person in
India has a national id and that,
that national ID is connected to their
biometrics so that they're able to access
that at any time.
Um,
national identity is a
significant issue for poor people.
Many of them don't have identity,
they don't have a birth certificate,
they don't have any sort of government
documentation. And without that,
they're significantly limited in their
ability to open a bank account in their
ability to access government services
and their ability to be recognized in
their ability to vote.
Um, and so for India,
making the commitments to establish this
national identity and connecting it to
bio metrics has been a significant
investment and a significant advancement
towards their end to poverty.
Once people are in the system,
they're able to access their
government benefits. Um,
they all automatically have a
bank account that's open for them.
So they're government benefits transfer
directly from the government into their
accounts without having to pass
through other hands what's making,
which makes sure that they
receive all of their benefits.
And the development of that system
was a development initiative.
It was funded by the gates foundation
and collaboration with the Indian
government, um, and many other
development initiatives. So, um,
another one which many of you may have
heard of is in Pesa in east Africa,
which is a mobile money system
connected to the Vodafone system there.
So although only 15% of
Kenyans have a bank account,
over 90% of Kenyans use a mobile money
account connected to their mobile phone.
Um,
and randomized controlled trials have
verified that over six per cent of people
annually move out of poverty because
of their access to mobile money.
And there's several reasons for that.
One is that it increases their resilience.
Um, if somebody has a health
emergency, for example,
able to reach out to friends and family
near and far to see if they can gather
resources to cover that health emergency
rather than having to sell off,
say a productive asset in their household,
having to sell a cow,
which may be worth $100 just to pay
for $6 a health emergency, you know,
needing malaria medication for example.
So they're able to increase their
resilience through their social networks,
through the mobile money platform, um, and
able to retain more of their assets. Um,
for women it's an important resource to,
they're able to save and save somewhere
often that is more private, um,
and away from say their husband or other
family members who may want access to
their resources.
So for women in particular,
having a safe and private place to save
is a very important part of their, um,
ability to have more control
over their own resources.
We live in amazing times and
with this technology development,
much of it happening here at Google and
many of you so hopefully involved in
some of it, we're seeing big
data, the use of cell phones, um,
being part of this,
the host of disruptive technologies that
are transforming the way we work in the
developing community, the way
that we engage with partners, um,
and giving us really unprecedented
opportunities to make impacts on poverty.
Grameen Foundation, we're
really passionate about
disrupting global poverty.
We're working to create breakthroughs
that will reach many of those still living
in poverty.
We just design strategies that women
and their families with knowledge and
services. We really look at how
we engage with frontline workers,
people who are already engaged with poor
households to improve their ability to
deliver products and services to them.
And we bring together
partners in an ecosystem.
So we work primarily with software
companies, with private sector entities,
with governments to ensure that solutions
we develop our embedded in sustainable
delivery mechanisms,
whether that's sustainable private sector
initiatives or sustainable governance
initiatives.
Okay.
Many of you may know Grameen Foundation.
See,
I think I got ahead of myself on
the slides. Um, through our history,
we were founded in 1997 through the work
of Muhammad Yunus Nobel laureate for
his work as the father of micro finance.
His breakthrough idea was really that,
that for women were someone you could
invest in, that you could lend to them,
they would invest that money in their
businesses and that they would repay it.
And we really have grown
on the back of that, um,
idea that poor households
are good investments and
someone you can do business
with.
In our first 10 years,
we really focused on micro finance and
developing micro finance institutions
globally. But in the last 10 years,
we have built on that foundation.
We've really focused on using digital
technology to develop sustainable
solutions to reach the poor,
especially women. Today,
our mission is both
urgent but also hopeful.
It's urgent because 60% of the chronically
hungry people are still women and
girls. They are disproportionately
affected by poverty and global hunger.
Though global poverty is on the decline.
Global hunger is on the rise.
2 billion people.
More than half of them women have
no access to formal financial,
which is a key enabler to life.
More than a hundred million people are
driven into poverty every year because of
a health crisis and that's not a
developing country phenomenon alone.
That's a phenomenon here,
right here in the U S and
maternal mortality rates in
Africa remained virtually
unchanged over the last three decades,
so there is an urgent need to continue
to invest in finding solutions to global
poverty.
At the same time,
we're hopeful digital technologies
are offering unprecedented solutions,
things like human centered design and
private sectors to increased focus on
working with the extremely poor,
provide opportunities that
we've never had before.
Looking forward to Grameen Foundation is
looking to reach 25 million people over
the next 25 years and move them
sustainably out of poverty.
Today we work in three main areas.
We work in digital financial
services for women.
We work in a digital innovations in
agriculture, and then we worth in health,
health financing and access.
Health financing and access is
primarily connected to our work,
particularly around financial
services and agriculture.
I wanted to highlight a
couple of our programs.
I thought you guys might be
particularly interested in.
The first one is called the can network,
the community agent
network in the Philippines.
I think everybody's familiar
with the Philippines.
It's an island nation is made
up of over 7,000 islands,
which it makes it extremely
expensive and time consuming, um,
for people to access financial services.
And it makes it extremely expensive for
financial service providers to build out
infrastructure across all of those 7,000
small islands. So we have worked with,
um, women like this with
Joan who are small, uh,
what are called, sorry, sorry.
Shop owners, kiosk owners.
They run little small businesses. They
smell, they sell daily household items.
And we have worked with a technology
provider to equip these women with a will
be called a point of sale or pos device
that enables them to PR to do mobile
money and digital payment transactions
for members of their community.
So now Joan who was on a small island
in the Philippines is able to be the
intersection point for her
island and for her community,
for people to pay their electricity
bill for people to make a deposit or
withdrawal into their bank account.
Um,
and this is enabling financial inclusion
to reach these small islands and people
who've never had access to it before.
Um,
to today we've trained over
18,000 or sorry, 1800 agents,
75% of them women like Joan.
Um,
we cater to 423 low income
neighborhoods across this island nation.
We facilitated over 4.3
million transactions,
valued at 1.3 billion pesos.
So there was a huge unmet demand for
these types of digital financial services.
And as soon as we were able to put an
access point in these communities, um,
you saw the,
the amount of people who were using
digital mobile money really ramp up the
other project we're engaged in,
which I thought you guys might find
interesting as a project we call sat for.
It's a project that just launched
this year and it's part of our global
partnership with Mars, which
is the chocolate company, um,
makes most of our candy bars these days.
Um,
and in this project we use satellite
digital imagery and data to reach 240,000
smallholder cocoa farmers across Ghana.
It's helped them increase their yields,
um, improve their incomes and
build stronger businesses.
And what we do this the way we do this
as taking some of the precision farming
techniques that have been developed in
the developed world for use on large, uh,
large scale farms and large industrial
farms and try and take some of those
technologies and those techniques and
make them work for smallholder farmers.
So things like satellite imagery
to help understand whether,
sorry, um, soil conditions and weather,
soil needs, additional nutrients, um,
to understand if soil, um, needs,
if you're farm needs more or less water
drain any particular point of view. Um,
you can use satellite data imagery to
understand whether the pruning on a
particular farm has been done correctly.
And weirdly,
pruning is very important for cacau trees
and helps improve their productivity.
So making sure that it's done
correctly is, is an important thing.
So we work with, um, Mars and,
and some of the partners on the
ground who have these field agents,
extension agents, we call them who already
go out and interact with the farmers.
So we're able to use satellite imagery
and satellite data to provide information
to the extension agents so that
when they go out and visit a farmer,
they can tell them you need to improve
your pruning techniques. We can see that,
that your trees need to be pruned
more. Um, we can see that, uh,
your soil is low in nitrogen and you need
to plant additional plants in order to
increase the nitrogen, um,
nitrogen in your plants.
And so it's really taking that technology
that's already in use for these large
scale farms and figuring out how we can
use it to increase small scale farmers
productivity and that their income.
And many people don't realize that cocoa
farmers are some of the poorest people
in the world, even though
they're connected to this
global chocolate value chain.
There are high levels of child
labor in chocolate globally.
And so part of this work that we do is
not only improving their productivity,
but bringing these farmers
into a global digital system.
So their information gets, um,
gets into our system for each farm,
their farming practices, um, et cetera.
And then we are able to work with them,
did become fair trade certified to
become organic certified if that's what
they're looking for.
So it's a system that gives both
greater profitability to the farmer,
but also greater visibility of all of us
into the global chocolate value chain.
And, um, it's something that
we're working with Mars and, um,
and looking at blockchain is the kind of
next part of that so that as consumers,
everybody can have visibility into how
your chocolate products through Mars are
being produced and whether
they're fair trade certified,
whether they're apps and of child labor,
et Cetera.
So I know that that's something that,
um,
kind of both sides of the
coin can benefit from.
One cornerstone that's consistent across
all of our projects is our desire to
really use data and information
to track our programs were, uh,
I think in the developing
community still at the,
at the nascent stage of figuring out how
to use big data and some of these big
data sources to really bring to the
fight against poverty and hunger.
But we're trying to use the smart tools
and the data and the information that we
have on smallholder farmers to bring them
more fully into market systems and to
overcome some of their, their
challenges. Um, one of the things,
for example that we're
looking at doing now, uh,
we have worked with hundreds of thousands
of small holder farmers globally.
One of the biggest constraints that they
all have is access to finance because
they don't have a financial history. Many
of them don't have bank accounts. Um,
many of them have worked with a,
a mainstream or large
financial institution before.
They may do all of their lending and
borrowing locally through their community
or through, um, money lenders. Um,
so how can we help this data that
they've built up in our system?
We may have three to four years
worth of their farming data. Um,
we made a know exactly how much they've
spent. I'm invested in their farm.
We may know exactly how much they've
produced and what they've earned off of
that production for two or three years.
So how can we help them take that data
and turn it into a credit profile or a
credit score that they can then use,
um,
with the mainstream financial institution.
So we've already done some of that in
Columbia with coffee farmers and we're
looking to replicated
in, uh, Ghana with sorry,
and Uganda with coffee farmers and then
in Ghana and Cote d'Ivoire with these
cow farmers.
So we think that's something very exciting
and a real growth area for us in an
area where we can really use the data
that we already have to really make an
impact.
Um,
I think there's other exciting ways we
can start to think about using technology
globally to alleviate poverty.
I talked about blockchain. Um,
it's something that we're all trying to
figure out what the best way to use is
this new technology and ways
that it can help impact poverty.
One of the ways that we're thinking
about Grameen Foundation is particularly
with refugees as they cross borders
and are receiving healthcare,
say in a country that is not their own.
How can they develop a health record
on something like blockchain that helps
them as they,
as they move globally,
whether they repatriate to their home
country or whether they're moved on to a
third country, how can they take
their health records with them?
Something like blockchain is something
that can really be very helpful with that.
Um, we're experimenting with artificial
intelligence and augmented reality. Um,
particularly in our India office,
we've been working with Accenture
development partners, um,
and using artificial intelligence,
for example,
we do a lot of financial
literacy training.
So using artificial intelligence to
help us understand how much women have
understood and internalized the training
that they've received and where women
need additional support, uh, to
ensure that they, they understand,
uh, how to use financial
services appropriately. So
I've actually done it myself,
done the little Q and. A. Um, and
it's very interesting to get the,
the readout in the reports on,
uh,
on how you're doing and how well you're
understanding of the lessons that you've
just received. So it's, it's exciting. Um,
and another exciting area we're looking
at is remote sensing for agricultural
irrigation.
So again,
it's something that's that's being used
by large scale industrial farms and
developing countries about
can we use remote sensing, um,
to help smallholder farmers in India,
um,
use water more efficiently
and water more effectively.
So that's a project that we're
just at the beginning of.
Okay.
So I'm going to end it with that.
Um,
and I'm really happy to answer any
questions anybody has or talk a little bit
more about our work.
We at Grameen are very excited about
the ability to use technology, um,
and information, uh, to end
extreme poverty and hunger.
We think these can help
create the breakthroughs
that will move women in their
communities out of poverty
in a sustainable way.
And we think it can be helped
with the work that you know,
people at Google are doing.
So we're really excited to talk with
you guys today more about the work we're
doing,
um,
and hear more about if you guys think
you're working on anything that's,
that's relevant or could be adapted. Um,
we're really excited to hear about it.
I will say that my
colleague be is over here,
so if you want to sign up for a
newsletter to learn more about Grameen
Foundation, she's the one to see. Um,
but with that I'll end and see
if anybody has any questions.
I'm just curious about where are you see
the intersections of Google's work and
um,
development.
So antipoverty or anti hunger
efforts or job training or other,
uh, you know, significant efforts
that'll have an impact on,
on social wellbeing.
Yeah, I feel probably, you know,
you got google.org our philanthropic arm
because they work with non profits and
Jacqueline pooler. I mean she
really understand a lot about that.
I think that this,
actually,
I met with Jacqueline
in a renal last week.
So I think that they definitely
are a good point to one of contact.
The other thing is that we are working
my cell like working Google developer
relations.
We deal technology and we
work with developers and uh,
we have these trainings around the world
with the book focused on social impact
because of course we
work with big companies,
but this is based on social impact
and we are part of grow with Google,
which is becoming a global
initiative in the u s Europe,
India, Indonesia recently launch
in Africa as well in Nigeria,
in a Google for urea.
So in addition to this developer trainees,
we do like a internet in railway stations,
the skills training, many of the
things that you were talking about,
I mean just getting people increase
their ability to get employed and that's,
we do.
So of course we are part
of Google cloud platform,
which all the technology is
there. And then so, uh, whatever,
I mean we have the cloud.
So interesting. I mean,
we can probably follow up and see if we
can figure out if we can collaborate in
some way or another.
Thank you.
Yeah, thanks. That would be very exciting.
I think especially with some
of the skills training pieces,
that's something that we're always
being asked for. Uh, so, uh,
do you see any, do you see the problem
of global poverty getting worse with like
desertification,
and the loss of variable land basically
due to global warming and climate change?
Absolutely. And I think it's, it's
very geographically specific, so,
and there are parts of the world
that are being impacted differently.
So for example,
you see areas like Mozambique or the
Philippines that are being subjected to
much more frequent natural disasters.
So Mozambique for example, yeah, mmm.
Is,
is much more frequently being hit by
typhoons or significant rains that are
causing flooding that are causing crop
loss, that are causing loss of life.
So we're seeing those issues hit
some countries at the same time.
We're seeing other countries,
particularly kind of the [inaudible]
region countries were increasing.
Desertification, um, is impact, you know,
encroaching on areas that
were former breadbaskets. Um,
and that we're producing
significant amounts of food.
So there are different impacts everywhere,
but without a doubt,
particularly the developing world is
being disproportionately impacted by
climate change and they
are disproportionately not
contributing to climate
change. I guess. I guess the actual, uh,
the question to the foundation is a,
are you doing anything to try to
prevent that from happening? Like,
is it easier to prevent people getting
into poverty because of those then try to
pull them out of it afterwards?
Oh yeah, absolutely.
So one of the projects we've initiated,
for example in the Philippines
is an early warning system.
So it's both a weather and
a pest early warning system.
So one of the things we're seeing with
climate change is very different pest
patterns globally, right? Because, um, uh,
mosquitoes or one that a lot of people,
it's not a, it's not a crop pest,
but you know,
mosquitoes are coming into areas that
they've never been before because the
climate in that area has changed.
So similarly with crop related pests,
they are coming into areas
where they've never been before.
We're farmers don't know
how to deal with them. Um,
and as well as weather related risks,
particularly in the Philippines.
So in the Philippines we've worked with
both the Ministry of Agriculture and a
local university that has a,
that runs the weather
stations in the country, um,
to develop an early warning system.
So that early warning system sends
information to farmers if there's an
inclement weather event or if there
is a pest outbreak in their area.
And not only does it tell them about the
event, but it gives them instructions.
So for example,
if there's,
there's a typhoon coming at may
tell farmers you need to cover your,
your trees and burlap and
may tell them you need to,
you need to harvest early because
there'll be total crop loss.
You should harvest what you can.
Now at the same time,
it allows for two way communication.
So say a farmer finds a pest in their
crop, if they're not familiar with,
they can take a picture of it,
they can send it into the system,
they can receive information
pack on what to do about it.
But at the same time he will triangulate.
So several farmers in in an
area report the same pest.
It will then send out a warning to all
farmers in the area that the pest has
been spotted in their area and
how they should treat for it.
So early warning system is something that
we're working on that we've piloted in
the Philippines. We're working on in ag,
integrating it into the scanner project.
I was talking about another project.
So yes.
Thank you.
So that may have been way more
detailed than you want it.
Yeah.
Can I add to that a little course as well.
So farmers are,
the majority of the world's poor,
70% of the extreme poor are farmers.
So a lot of what we do is in terms of
helping those farmers increase their
productivity and the
sustainability of what they do,
which is part and parcel of
adjusting to climate change.
So I don't know if you want to maybe talk
a little bit about the savings groups
work like in,
in Burkina Faso and how
we're directly doing that.
Yeah, absolutely. I think climate
adaptation is, is a big issue. Um,
and it's, it's both a financial
issue. And it's an agricultural issue.
So when Burkina Faso,
we work with women who in a lot of times,
particularly in Africa,
you'll see that men are often
engaged in what we call cash crops.
So they grow a crop crop that can be
sold at market and women are engaged in
household food crops.
And so we engage women and
working a Faso in savings groups.
So they get together on a regular basis.
They save weekly,
usually a very small amount, um, and
they, they're able to pull that savings,
then they can borrow from it if
they need for an investment. Um,
but at the end of the year,
then they receive their savings back
and they're able to invest in it.
So as part of that project,
we worked with those
women on understanding the
impacts of climate change in
their region and helping
them to modify or adopt,
adapt what crops they're growing. So we
worked with a lot of wind, for example,
to start growing cow peas or cassava or,
and different kinds of, um, orange yams,
which are much more drought
resistance and tolerance.
Given the changes that are having,
a lot of times what happens particularly
in these rural communities is that
people have been engaged for generations
in farming a certain type of crop and
they really understand that crop and as
climate change happens and they need to
move into crops that are going to be
more appropriate given what their new
climate reality is,
they don't have that level of skill
and understanding of that crop. Um,
and so helping them have the information
on what crops are going to work for
them now and how they should grow it
and how to it et Cetera is an important
part of our work. And then making sure
they have the resources to invest in it.
It's very risky for smallholder
farmers. You know, um, I,
cassava is one of my, the things
I dislike most in this world, um,
because it's a very drought resistant
crop and it grows almost everywhere.
So a lot of people have a lot of
incentive to grow cassava because um,
it will come in no matter what and you,
you will be able to
feed your family on it.
It is a very low nutrient cause office,
like a Yam kind of yellow. Yeah.
But it doesn't have the
nutrients that yams do. Um,
and particularly for young
children it's hard to digest.
So you see young children who eat a
lot of cassava actually tend to be more
malnourished then even though they're,
they're getting a lot of calories
because they can't digest them very well.
They tend to be extremely malnourished.
But people planted
because it fills Belize.
And so if we can give people
the information they need
on other crops that we'll
do as well as cassava,
but we'll have much more nutritional
benefit for the household,
like yellow and orange, sweet
potatoes, um, like cow peas,
which are extremely drought resistant.
If we can help them to understand
these new crops that they can be using,
which are readily available in
their areas and how to harvest them,
not only will they potentially
have a better harvest,
but it will be more
nutrient rich food for them.
Um, I was wondering about mobile financial
services and, and device security.
Like a lot of these cheaper android
devices basically never get security
updates.
Um,
have you found any practices that help
protect people if they're acting as like
the financial agent for
their whole village of, of
keeping their device secure?
Yes.
Um,
I would say the device security is
probably pretty low on a lot of people's
priority lists.
Um,
what is high and where I think we're
seeing a lot of momentum is moving people
towards a better, more and
better smartphones. Um,
so you see a lot of people,
still,
most people particularly in Africa
are still using, well Africa, India,
most developing countries are
still using feature phones.
So the big push is to try and get
people on to smart phones, um,
and to get people more access to data.
Um,
because even when people moved to smart
phones, data can be very expensive still.
So the short answer to your question is
not really doing a lot on device security
feature phones,
like more resistant to malware
then typical smartphone.
I don't know the answer to that.
My guess would be yes.
Only because it doesn't have
very many features. You know,
they don't have very many features
for people to mess with. Um,
and usually then when you're
using a feature phone,
you're using USSD or SMS technology
to access your accounts or to do your
transactions so high. I was curious
about something you said about uh,
using blockchain for a medical records.
I was curious what makes that
specifically about technology specifically
suitable that purpose versus,
you know,
some other database platform
or some other system. Yeah,
I think one of the things that makes
blockchain interesting in that particular
use case, and it's one we're still
exploring, we haven't implemented yet,
is the ability for those records to be
transferable across borders and to be
accessible through biometrics.
So if a person, um, you know,
returns to their home country,
a lot of times when people, uh,
when refugees cross borders,
they don't take their national,
they don't have documentation with them
so they don't have their national ids,
et Cetera.
So the ability to build biometrics into
that and to make it accessible when
people cross borders are what makes
blockchain particularly interesting.
In a lot of these cases, I'm sort
of a, like the, you should only,
I think a lot of people are very bullish
on blockchain and I'm also bullish on
blockchain,
but I think people want to use it a
lot of times when you could just use a
regular database. And so, and
there there's, so there is,
um, and so, you know,
I've heard people tell me,
even if it's just a regular database,
go ahead and put it in blockchain because
that's where the world is moving. Um,
and then other people have said, you
know, it's, it's a complicated technology.
If you could just use a database,
just use the database.
So we're probably still on the,
just use the database side of things,
but people are throwing me up. So I'm
just, I'm hoping that's the right answer.
Let's
help
you gain insights from Yep.
So I'll just repeat it in
case the question was what,
because we have such a
large amount of data,
what our position is on
sharing that publicly. Um,
which is a good question and I have a
good answer because I was just meeting
with our tech person this
morning. Um, so we are in,
we have a huge amount of
data in different systems.
So we're going through a process
right now of cleaning that data.
I think we're very open to sharing
it. Um, in a couple of ways. One,
we're open to anonymizing it and
sharing it widely so that people can do
research with it.
Um,
we're also open to sharing it and in ways
that allow people to provide services
to Pacific specific farmers.
So for example,
we have a lot of farm data in Uganda and
we are working now actively on making
that accessible to financial institutions
so that they can identify farmers who
need to invest in their farms
and lend to them. What we are,
um, quite specific on is that that needs
to be a relationship that the farmer
understands and agrees to. So say, um,
centenary bank is one of
our partners in Uganda,
which is a large bank national bank.
So say centenary bank wants to access
a farmer's data to see if they want to
make a loan to them, that
the farmer either needs to
receive an SMS and say, yes,
I consent to centenary or the farmer
needs to be able to push their data.
So they,
the farmers talked to the centenary bank.
If they want to send them their data,
they can push it from the system. So the,
there needs to be a consent process
where the end user is able to consent.
Because when we originally collected
their data, we didn't understand, uh,
you know, some of them may have started
five years ago. We didn't know what,
what we could be doing with it.
They didn't consent at that
time to sharing it widely. Um,
going forward, um, you know, we may have
different kinds of consent protocols,
but I think it's important.
And this gets back to the
blockchain thing a little bit. Um,
for people don't understand all of the
things you could be doing with their data
and where their data could be
going. And, um, even if you,
if they sign a consent form,
does,
is that really meaningful consent if
they don't understand what we're all
talking about with this big data stuff.
And so how can you make
their data available but
still give them some level of
control over it. We talk a lot about
particularly because, you know,
we work sometimes in refugee situations,
what are people's rights to anonymity,
right? To be forgotten. Um,
and what are the dangers that go along
with people's state of being publicly
available. So, um, anyway, it's
something we think along well.
Um, so I grew up in farming in Florida
and a lot of the industrialized techniques
that we had were kind of makes sense
because of economy of scale and heavy
equipment and stuff like that.
Um,
how much of of that
industrialized techniques,
how many of those apply? And
have you looked into, uh,
any sort of research with more specific
techniques, smaller techniques?
So that all depends. Um, and I'm going
to say I'm not an agriculture expert. Um,
but so things like data for farming is
something that you could parse out pretty
easily and cheaply. Um,
other technologies like, um,
I don't know. I'm trying to think. Um,
like there's a lot of work that's
been done, not necessarily by us,
but like around cooperative
ownership of technology,
whether that technology is a large,
um,
what's the word I'm looking for? Harvest
or harvest or there we go. Thank you. Um,
or you know, other machinery, you know,
cooperative ownership and cooperative
movements are big in developing countries
as well as in the u s um,
but data I think is something that can
be parsed out to the individual farmers
so that they can take action on it.
So to add onto that,
I do think even in the developing world,
farm fragmentation is an
issue we deal with, um,
particularly because of climate change as,
as arable land is shrinking in some
areas. Um, you know, you have a farmer,
he has so much land, he has three sons.
It gets divided among the three sons.
They have three sons,
it gets divided.
And so there is a consolidation process
that needs to happen in the developing
world. Um, and it's a lot
of what we talk about. Um,
it gets to maybe some of the skills
training opportunities because there needs
to be off farm rural enterprise
that can pull labor off of farms,
allow for farm consolidation in a lot of
countries to make smallholding farming
more profitable
as somebody,
as somebody at Google who
mostly spends time, you know,
thinking about consumer technologies
and sometimes enterprise technologies in
the development world.
Um,
I am curious what you've
seen ouch. You know, in,
in the developing world
as far as interesting or
surprising uses of technologies
that we've developed here. You know, big
products like, like Gmail or you know,
android phones or you know, contacts
and address book is, is the,
the area where I work now, what have
you seen out there? You know, them,
them using the products
that we've developed in
interesting and surprising ways.
Good question. Um, I
think it's interesting.
I lived for seven years in Tanzania.
I came home about two or three years ago
and I was amazed how many people here
don't use what's up.
Like in the W in east Africa,
what's up is the primary
mode of communication and
what's up is now being used
and piloted for mobile
money transfers. So, um,
so I think there's a lot of interesting
things that are happening in developing
countries that aren't happening here.
It's interesting. I went to, um,
one of those like,
Aha moments for me.
I went to one of these women's
savings groups in Kenya, um,
and we had worked with them with a
partner bank. Um, and so they were,
they had a savings account, um, on their,
on their mobile phone that
they could deposit into.
And so I was asking the woman, um,
one of the women in this group, okay,
you have a savings account. What's
the account you want to, you know,
what type of financial product do you
want next on your phone? You know,
do you want access to credit?
Do you want to insurance?
Do you want Agricultural Credit?
She said,
just put them all on my phone and I'll
decide what, you know, what I want to use.
So the hunger for these tech solutions
is really, is really, really high.
I talked to a woman same day, um,
in a different group who said, God,
I had to turn Facebook off on my phone
because, um, I was just using it too much.
And this was, I had flown on an
airplane to a secondary city.
I had driven an hour.
I had taken a boat across the lake
and gotten to this rural community.
It was like a four hour trek to get there.
Um,
and here's a woman telling
me I use Facebook too much.
I have to turn it off
because it's distracting me.
So the hunger for technology is really,
really high in these communities.
Um,
and there's,
I think sort of this myth that a lot of
these communities aren't very tech savvy,
but, um, they're really, um,
taking up a lot of this technology.
Thanks. And I, and I have
a another question too. As
long as I'm up here you go.
Google is full of idealistic people
with software engineering skills. Um,
if one of those people,
you know,
hypothetically wanted to put those skills
to work and the growth and the growth
number or poverty, um, what
are the opportunities that
are out there, you know,
on either volunteer or
fulltime basis or whatever.
One of my colleagues will be
so excited that you asked. Um,
we have a program in Grameen Foundation,
inappropriately named
Bankers Without Borders. Um,
because it started in our early days
when we were focused primarily on micro
finance,
but it is a volunteer program that lets
working professionals volunteer their
time,
um,
either here from the u s providing kind
of remote assistance or traveling to a
developing country to work with a local
partner for, you know, two to three weeks.
Um, and so it's a volunteer program and
we work with our partners in developing
countries who have needs for assistance
and with professionals here to try and
match them up. So, um, if you see be,
she'll get you some information and
anyone else who wants to volunteer their
time and get you some information on
the banker's without Borders program and
you can sign up. And
some of it's as, um, as,
and time consuming as say we're working
with a small business in east Africa
that,
um,
is thinking about using the technology
in a certain way and they just want to
have a brainstorm
session with some people.
And so they'll set up an ideation session,
Grameen Bank, so that board as well. Um,
and maybe try and find,
you know,
five or six professionals here in the US
or in Europe who can just sit and on a,
you know,
a Skype call or a Webex and talk through
with the CEO kind of what technology
might fit his needs. Um, and
then it could be everything from,
we have people who do, do, you know,
year long fellowships funded by their
employers, um, you know, to sit,
um,
you know,
in a partner and really work with them
in depth over the course of a year and
then everything kind of in between.
So if you're interested in volunteering,
definitely look at that PR program
and sign up for it. It's really,
it's really amazing. Great.
Thank you. Thanks so much.
I'm going to let the Google guy go first.
Uh, I want to understand how, uh, what
kind of parameters that you look at,
um, you know, on deciding do you want to
service this country or this area or not?
Cause I'm sure there's like a lot of
areas that need, you know, your service.
So how do you decide that?
That's a very good question.
Um,
I think one of the things for Grameen
Foundation is that we are really looking
at sustainable solutions.
So we often have opportunities to work
on initiatives that we think can benefit,
um, you know, maybe 10, 15,000 people,
but we don't understand long term how
we would make that sustainable. Um,
could we,
could we embed it in a government could
be embedded in a private sector for us.
If we can't understand the
longterm sustainability, um,
it's a project that we would probably
pass up on. Um, it's just not,
and,
and there are other groups who could do
that and maybe do a good job and it has
a benefit.
But our longterm DNA is to
look for something that can
be long term sustainable.
We are an organization that
has a heavy tech history.
Um,
and so primarily we're
looking at opportunities
where we can identify ways to
use technology, um, in ways that can
maybe leapfrog or our fine, you know,
disruptive innovations to solutions.
So that being said, you know, it's,
it's sort of a case by case basis.
Um,
we almost always want a local
partner on the ground, um,
be that private sector or government
or a, or a local entity, um,
who can do the implementation and
who can be the long term owner of it.
The local partners reach out to you as
do they initiate the first contact or do
you use kind of see opportunities
and then reach out to the,
that really can depend. Um,
you know, sometimes if we,
if we have an opportunity,
if you stayed puts out a call, we may go
out and look for a particular partner.
Um, other times somebody
might come to us and say,
um, so Mussolini is, is a
good example of that there.
The first all digital micro
finance institution in Kenya.
And so they came to us,
um, saying, uh, you know,
we're looking at [inaudible],
we really want to build out an
agricultural financing products.
So can you help us think through
that? So we worked with them, um,
and we had some EWB volunteers who worked
with them to help think through what
an agriculture finance project,
a product would look like I'm enrolled
and how they could roll that out across
the organization and it's now become
their most profitable product.
So it works both ways a
little bit. Thank you. Thanks.
Thanks you guys so much for coming.
I was really a worry.
Nobody would come and then we're,
nobody would ask any questions.
So I really appreciate it. Appreciate
your time and the work Google is doing.
Cause I know many things that you guys
do are really contributing to the work
that we'd oversee.
So thanks so much.